tigers matt manning on the mountain
today this is uh what is his 13th start
with tigers 94 innings between toledo
and detroit last start career high five
strikeouts
and he struck him out another one in 96
just poured it in there
for the first strikeout of the day
he walked him
olsen with the chopper to second
took an abnormal hop
a willy castro handled it another 3-2
in the dirt and chapman draws the wall
so 1-0 to lowry with two on and two out
couple of walks here in the top of the
first inning
lowry drives one toward left center
field it's hit well and then that baby's
gone
two walks and a three-run shot and the
a's lead
well step on it jed lowry a fastball
kite this is down this is inner third
jed lowry like he's folding laundry a
little inside out all aboard
next stop pound town there's mark cannon
that one's hit well to right field
reyes is back and that baby's gone
canada goes the opposite way four to
nothing the a's lead well the big league
foodie strikes again
who's hungry
can i get an oppo taco
mark canna says
i'll oblige another fastball up and out
how about the youngsters
pumped let's go
and it's time to bash baby frankie
montos making his 27th start of the
season he's already set a career high in
victories this season coming off a
couple of great outings
96 and it's popped up down the third
base line
and it'll be tony kemp who grabs it
chapman throws across to get scope
here's the pitch and that comes back
over the inside corner ring him up and
the tigers go down one two three and
after one it's four nothing athletics
one out then here comes elvis andrews
elvis andrews got a pitch right up out
over the plate
lines it to right for a hit here's
charlie marte
marte linesman toward left it's going to
be pass grossman drops right at the base
of the wall
elvis anders is going to be waved home
here comes the throw to the plate and he
is
safe at the plate and all the way to
third goes marte and it's five to
nothing
so marte with an rbi double goes to
third on the throw and even with two
outs here and andrew's moving on the
crack of the bat the ace catch a break
you'll see this ball
check up at the base of the wall
and so robbie grossman expecting to play
a carom
it just never happens so he's got to go
and
get out to the wall and pick that ball
up and that's what gives elvis enough
time
so two outs here in the top of the third
here's camp who grounded out to end the
first
it's this one up the middle into center
field and that's a base hit
so tony kemp goes after the first pitch
he has a hit that's five hits now for
the a's so two on two out again for the
a's here's yon gomes
that one is hit well toward left center
field grossman on the move and grossman
has a tip off his glove
cannon's going to score
kemp is also going to score it's a
two-run double for john gomes and now
it's seven to nothing seven to nothing
the a's lead bottom of the third they've
scored in every inning
and he got him just went right with that
fastball at 97 miles an hour a very well
placed fastball so one away here's
victor reyes the o2 swinging a fly ball
to center that's hit hard going back
marty turned one way the other and he
won't find that ball as he goes all the
way to the wall in straight away center
victor wright is full head of steam
around second heading to third and he
will make it without a throw he smoked
that over the head of marte who turned
the wrong way by the time he turned back
to his right the ball was buying it's a
one out triple for victor reyes
and that one is
hit on the ground towards short coming
home the tag and they got him
so a close play at the plate alva
sanders had a decision to make do i
just get the shirt out at first or do i
try to cut the run down he went home
and they got reyes
and scope one around is sean barber the
home plate umpire calls it scope could
not hold up so the a's keep the tigers
off the board two bouncer brings up matt
olson
goes with the fastball and it's lined
toward left center field for a hit
olson with a big turn he'll stop there
chapman lines it that's a base hit
grossman over gets it back in quickly
and a pair of
two out base hits by olson and chapman
and it looks like that may be it for
young matt manning so the new pitcher is
miguel del pozo with the ace leading at
seven to nothing and now threatening for
more look who's gonna pinch it chris
davis and the first pitch is lined into
the left field corner olson's gonna
score here comes chapman chapman is
being waved home but robbie grossman
puts his arms up don't know if that ball
bounced over the wall either way
it's gonna be a double it's just a
matter of
one or two runs scoring now
chris davis is just going to keep going
well
because if this has ruled a playable
ball then chris davis would be able to
keep going but since it's not he'll take
his
little walk back to second and call it
hey kd
i love the effort tigers bad fifth
inning eight nothing oakland
castro to deep center field that ball is
crushed and gone
what's gotten into harold castro
that was a bomb
what has gotten in here wow
right off the bat goodness
just out over the plate look at that bad
angle
drives right through
into the bushes that's the upper level
of bushes that's how far that traveled
so it's the bottom of the sixth inning
in detroit frankie montos will face
grossman
one two pitch good splitter and that is
strikeout number seven for frankie
montas
nastiness
lying to left kemp backs up a little bit
lost the last two times he has hit a
couple balls very hard both at tony kemp
first pitch swinging hero castro
hits one toward kemp kemp waits he's got
it and that'll do it hit nothing else
we're on to the seventh with the a's
leading it eight to one
castro's at first with two outs
before he killed badou
fly ball left field
that goes tony count he's at the wall
it's gone
a two-run blast for aquila madu
second homer man has many nights
well it's good to see that nikhil madu
no we talked last night about striking
out his first two at bats and coming
back and having three good at bats
tigers are down here he keeps pushing on
his level of intensity never wave two on
two out and here's jamer candelario
fly ball deep right field
back it goes and it is gone
a three-run blast and the a's have to be
uncomfortable now
remember the previous pitch we just
showed you down and away just stayed
alive and here it comes that's why you
do it next pitch down the middle
8-6
number 11 on the season for jamer
candelario sergio romo comes in he's
going to try to pick up a save folks
last outing was a save it was against
the yankees
[Music]
and he got him on three pitches three
sliders hill strikes out
and that one is hit well the left center
field going back is canna he's going to
have just enough room on the warning
track and he makes the catch
2-2 pitch
grounded toward alva sanders he's going
to throw across and it is dug out by
olson and that is the ball game so the
a's thought it was going to be a laugher
turns out they had a hang on and sergio
romo gets his second save of the year
and he saves it for frankie montos
you